hey youtubers is Charlie so I finally
got to see the new Godzilla movie so I
wanted to do a review we haven't seen a
kaiju movie in a little while the most
recent one has been Pacific Rim and that
was kind of like Guillermo del Toro's a
love letter to Godzilla which is really
awesome - I love that movie
since this movie is also something of a
reboot of the franchise I'll talk about
where it fits in the timeline of all the
other Godzilla movies if you're finding
me for the first time I try to do movie
reviews of all my favorite sci-fi and
fantasy movies so be sure to subscribe
to get everything
I'll be doing this future pass next week
and then there's Maleficent and How to
Train Your Dragon 2 so before I do my
review here's a super quick breakdown of
where this new movie fits in the
chronology of all the other Godzilla
movies it's kind of like a spiritual
sequel to the original 1954 movie not
really a direct sequel but it presents
the events of the first film as a
real-life historical event and combines
that story with things that actually
happened in US military history we can
talk more about that during spoilers
though for all intents and purposes
though this movie pays homage to all
those other Godzilla movies you don't
have to have seen any of them to
understand what's going on though which
is kind of nice especially for new
viewers but if you're a huge Godzilla
fan you'll notice all the little bits
from the older movies that they used as
names for things in the new movie what I
mean is they gave a lot of things in the
new movie names based on things that
happen in the old movies so because the
movie is just coming out and a lot of
you might not have seen it yet I'm gonna
do a non-spoilery review first and then
I'll do a spoiler a part where I talk
about potential future sequels as well
you know specific points in the film
right off the bat Godzilla I totally
loved the way he was depicted in the
movie both his part of the story and
visually with the effects he's the star
but I noticed a lot of people were
surprised by the amount of screen time
he got and I saw some criticism from
hardcore Japanese audiences on the way
he looked I understand where a lot of
the complaints are coming from based on
the way he was depicted in previous
movies but I thought that what they did
totally worked
and they did a really good job of
setting up potential sequels which by
all accounts will definitely be
happening right now the movie is
crushing it at the box office and we all
know how things work in the movie world
if it makes a ton of money there will
always be a sequel in terms of the non
Godzilla actors in the movie Bryan
Cranston was totally awesome Breaking
Bad has been off the air long enough
that I wasn't thinking Walter White
every minute he was on screen he's a
great actor
Aaron taylor-johnson and elizabeth Olsen
though we're just a little surreal to
watch together in case you didn't see
Winter Soldier they're both playing
Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch in
Avengers 2 so they're brother and sister
in that movie and in Godzilla they're a
married couple so all the x-men comic
book fans out there let me know if you
thought it was a little bit weird
watching them together on screen I think
my favorite actor in the film my
favorite human actor in the film was Ken
Watanabe I'll talk more about his
character in spoilers but I just love
the mythology that he brought to the
story the movie was totally upfront
about what it was you know it's a
disaster event movie with monsters in it
it's not like a psychological
exploration of Godzilla's motivation if
you want a movie like that you should
watch angley's Hulk which is funny
because that movie was made by Universal
a company that originated a lot of the
classic monster movies like Dracula and
Frankenstein I didn't consider the movie
to be an origin story mostly because it
takes the events of the 1954 film and
treats that like a historical event but
I do think it was something of a visual
reboot and if we're talking about the
logic of Godzilla you know explaining
how he could exist today I think all of
the Godzilla films have operated from
the idea that he's a prehistoric
creature that adapted biologically to
deal with intense amounts of radiation
so none of that's changed if you are new
to Godzilla films then you might be
confused by how Godzilla could survive
for millions and millions of years
though as a biological organism at some
point you'd have to age and die I didn't
really take issue with any of the logic
I try to operate based on the rules that
the movie presents like if you can grow
as big as Godzilla in your reptile maybe
you can hibernate for millions of years
- I don't like to nitpick things like
that too much overall I give the movie a
solid b-plus as a really fun monster
event disaster movie and did a really
good job of reinvigorating the franchise
that was really the task that it had to
perform make people excited to see
Godzilla movies again in a really big
way and it totally accomplished that so
let's drill into specifics and talk
about specific favorite moments so
careful for spoilers from the movie if
you haven't seen it yet but number 5 Ken
Watanabe finds the very first nest they
did a great job of hiding the fact that
there were multiple monsters so I loved
when they found that Muto lair inside
the Godzilla skeleton if you were
confused by what was going on there they
based
said that whatever that dead skeleton
was even if it wasn't a Godzilla monster
it was a creature that gave off
radiation but the Muto's fed on a long
time ago eventually a Muto killed it and
then laid its eggs inside of it so those
eggs could feed off the radiation that
that dead animals gave off just like the
bomb and the lair later in the movie
number four the male Muto hatches it's
like the world's coolest science
experiment just waiting for a monster
chicken egg to hatch I love the science
behind it to the creature feeding on
radiation for 15 years in its cocoon
until it hatched into a beautiful
butterfly of death and destruction on
two three the Muto mating ritual part of
me wants to think these animals aren't
evil they're only doing what they
naturally do eat things reproduce and
kill predators rinse and repeat
I wonder if the DVD special features
will describe some of the science about
how they reproduce because it's actually
pretty interesting maybe if we ask Emily
Garcia on brain scoop she can tell us
how animals like this would do it on to
number two
Godzilla history redefined I'm talking
mostly about the way they present
historical facts is that they were true
like the atomic bomb tests in the
Pacific in 1954 they also invoked the
Hiroshima bomb but that one they did not
tie to a Godzilla attack I also really
like the way Ken Watanabe mythologized
Godzilla as a warrior for balance you
know he's a hero just not for mankind
he's fighting on the side of nature so
that makes me wonder if at some point he
could attack man like if they ever
worked Mechagodzilla into the new
franchise and my number one moment
obviously Godzilla versus the Muto's let
them fight it was a great action scene
that pushed all the right fan buttons we
talked Godzilla's nuclear breath and he
got some really awesome close-up moments
I thought it was so much fun when
Godzilla furrowed his brow it was like
he was trying to do a Schwarzenegger
one-liner it just couldn't form the
words in his mouth but the way they
filmed that fight scene was also really
really cool they did a good job of
depicting scale and not showing you so
much of the monsters that it looked
silly but there was this one point when
I thought it looked kind of like a model
like they were paying homage to the
original Godzilla battles by making it
look like there were three rubber suits
fighting for a very very short amount of
time this is a real quick bonus moment
or maybe tied for my favorite moment was
that 2001 Space Odyssey scene where they
jump out the back of the
you see their red trails just going down
through the cloud cover it was so
beautiful it was like a painting if you
didn't hear it they used that famous
audio track from 2001 Space Odyssey that
plays whenever dave the astronaut is
passing through dimensions but now it's
your turn let me know below in the
comments what was your favorite moment
and did you catch any really awesome
Easter eggs to the old films just to
talk about sequels for a minute
since Godzilla did not die at the end I
don't expect them to do son of Godzilla
any time soon but I do want to see a
mech at some point maybe not a
straight-up mecha godzilla but now that
everyone knows about him how can the
governments of the world not build a
countermeasure they did a really good
job of explaining the other prehistoric
monsters or at least laying the
groundwork for that so I think we'll see
matera or some other monsters and future
sequels but let me know which monsters
do you want to see appear in the new
films in related news like I said I'm
doing it Days of Future past preview
next week be sure to subscribe to get it
also lots of orphan black in Game of
Thrones coming this weekend right now
click here to learn about my top 10
favorite Godzilla movies and click here
to learn all about Ben Affleck's new
Batsuit and the new Batmobile thank you
so much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow bye
you